في سياق اخر مشاهدينا قالت الخارجيه
الصينيه ان اقامه قواعد عسكريه جديده
لوشنطن سيؤدي لمزيد من التصعيد ورافت الى
ان واشنطن تعزز من انتشارها العسكري في
المنطقه وتزعزع استقارها واوضحت بكين انها
تعارض بشده اي اجتماع بين اي مسؤول امريكي
وتعهدت بدفاع عن سياده الصين كما ذكرت
الخارجي الصينيه ان دخول المنطاد الصيني
لاجواء امريكا كان حادثا مدنيا غير متوقع
متابع
او قواعد عسكريه امريكيه جديده في الفلبين
تثير غضب الصين
والتي تسعى للهيمنه على المنطقه بحسب
واشنطن
الا ان القواعد الامريكيه الجديده تعيق
الاهداف الصينيه
القواعد الامريكيه تقع بمناطق استراتيجيه
فالقاعده البحريه في مقاطعه كاجايان تبعد
400 كيلومتر فقط عن تايوان
اما القاعده الاخرى فتقع في جزيره بالاباك
بالقرب من بحر الصين الجنوبي ليكون عدد
القواعد الامريكيه في الفلبين 9 قواعد كما
يتم التفاوض بشان قاعده امريكيه عاشره
محتمله